so i've said that if you have a vector
field a two-dimensional vector field
with component functions p and q that
the divergence of this guy
the divergence of v
which is a scalar valued function of x
and y
is by definition the partial derivative
of p
with respect to x
plus the partial derivative of q
with respect to y
and there's actually another notation
for divergence that's kind of helpful
for remembering the formula and what it
is is you take this nabla symbol that
upside down triangle that we also use
for the gradient and imagine taking the
dot product between that and your vector
valued function and as we did with the
gradient the the loose mnemonic you have
for this upside down triangle as you
think of it as a vector full of partial
differential operators and that that
sounds fancy but all it means is you
kind of take this partial partial x a
thing that wants to take in a function
and take its partial derivative and
that's its first component and the
second component is this partial partial
y a thing that wants to take in a
function and take its partial derivative
with respect to y
and you know loosely this isn't really a
vector these aren't these aren't numbers
or functions or things like that but
it's something you can write down and
it'll be kind of helpful symbolically
and you imagine taking the dot product
with that and
you know v who has components
these scalar valued functions p of x y
and q
of x y
and when you imagine doing this dot
product and you're kind of lining up
terms and the first one multiplied by
the second right quote-unquote
multiplied because in this case when i
say this first component multiplied by p
i really mean you're taking that partial
derivative operator partial partial x
and evaluating it at p that's kind of
what multiplication looks like in this
case so you take that and as per the dot
product you then add what happens if you
take this partial operator this partial
partial y
and quote unquote multiply it with q
which in the case of an operator means
you kind of give it the function q and
it's going to take its partial
derivative so we see we get the same
thing over here it's the same formula
that we have
and it's just kind of a nice little
you could think of it as a pneumonic
device for
for remembering what the divergence is
but another nice thing this this can
apply to multi um
to higher dimensional functions as well
right if we have something that's uh
let's see
something that's a vector valued
function and it's going to be a three
dimensional vector field so it's got x y
and z as its inputs and its output then
also has to have three dimensions so it
might be like p
q
and r and all of these are functions of
x and y so that's p of x and y q
oh no no x y and z right so p of x y
kind of got in the habit of two
dimensions there p of x y and z
q of x y and z
and then r of x y and z and i haven't
talked about three-dimensional
divergence
but if you take this and then you
imagine doing your
nabla dotted with the vector-valued
function
it can still make sense and in this case
that nabla you're thinking of as having
three different components right it's
going to be on the one hand is partial
partial x
i should say partial x there
and the second component is partial
partial y and the last component is
partial partial z and the ordering of
these of the variables here x y and z is
just whatever i have here so even if
they didn't have the names x y z you
kind of put them in the same order that
they show up in your function
and when you imagine taking the dot
product between this
and your
p as a function q is a function and r is
a function
vector-valued vector-valued output
what you'd get and i'll write it over
here is
you take that partial partial x and kind
of multiply it
with p
which means you're really evaluating at
p so partial x here
then you add
partial partial y
and you're evaluating at q because
you're kind of imagining multiplying
these second components and then you'll
add what happens when you multiply by
these third components where that's
partial partial z
by that last component
and you know since i haven't talked
about three-dimensional vector fields or
three-dimensional divergence this last
term maybe it's not a given that you'd
have as strong an intuition for why this
shows up in divergence as the other two
but it's actually quite similar you're
thinking about changes to the z
component of a vector as the value z of
the input as you're kind of moving up
and down
in that direction changes but this this
pattern will go for even higher
dimensions that we can't visualize four
five 100 whatever you want and that's
that's what makes this notation here
quite nice is that it encapsulates that
and um gives a really compact way of
describing this formula that has a
simple pattern to it but would otherwise
kind of get out of hand to write
see you next video